[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه
نبدا بالعناوين
صواريخ غزه تطالب وسط اسرائيل ومسؤول
اسرائيلي يؤكد سنرد على النار بالنار
عن بدء الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاده
وسط ادانات دوليه تواصل الاقتتال بالسودان
واكثر من 190 مفقودا معظمهم مدنيون منذ
بدء المواجهات
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
قبيله ايام من الاقتراع انسحاب احد منافسي
اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
تركيا
[موسيقى]
من التطورات المتسارعه في غزه نبدا فقد
اطلقت العشرات من الصواريخ من قطاع غزه
وارشاد هذه الصور المباشره اذا اطلقت
العديد من الصواريخ قبل قليل على مستوطنات
الغلاف ووصل بعضها الى ريشون وسط اسرائيل
حيث اعترضتها منظومه القبه الحديديه وفيما
دوات صافرات الانذار باستمرار في مستوطنات
الغلاف قتل اسرائيلي واصيب اربعه اخرون
بعد سقوط صاروخ بشكل مباشر على مبنى في
منطقه روحفوط جنوب تل ابيب هذا واكد مسؤول
اسرائيلي فشل جهود التوصل لهن وقال ان
اسرائيل سترد على النار بالنار
ونتابع هذه الصور المباشره من انقطاع غزه
التي تعرضت اليوم للعديد من الغارات
وبالمقابل اطلقت منها رشقات
صاروخيه استهدفت الداخله الاسرائيلي
والان اطلاق دفعه صواريخ جديده اذا من
قطاع غزه استهدفت تحديدا جنوب عسقلان
قبل ذلك سنه القوات الاسرائيليه غارات
جويه ادت الى مقتل القيادي في حركه الجهاد
احمد ابو دقه رفقه ما ذكرت رويترز ومن
جهتها اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه عن
اصابه اربعه اشخاص في الغاره الاسرائيليه
بالقرب من خان يونس فيما لم تعلق القوات
الاسرائيليه عن الامر حتى الان
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
قال ان بلاده لا تزال في وسط العمليه
العسكريه سواء في الهجوم او الدفاع مشيرا
الى انها سترد على مطلق الصواريخ ومن يحل
محلهم
في وقت سابق من صباح اليوم قمنا باغتيال
قائد مجموعه صواريخ الجهات في غزه والان
منذ فتره وجيزه احتل نائبه ايضا اي شخص
ياتي ليؤذينا لن يجني سوى الدم على راسه
هو ومن يحل محله نحن في منتصف المعركه في
الهجوم والدفاع وسنواصل التقدم لحمايه
سمائنا وحياه مواطننا
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من غزه الصحفي احمد حرب اهلا
بك سيد احمد يعني يبدو ان صوت النار اقوى
من صوت المحادثات لاحلال الهدنه ما
العراقيل وما الضمانات المطلوبه من
الطرفين والتي يعني فيها عراقيل حتى الان
العراقيل هي تتمحور في ان هناك شروط
للفصاله الفلسطينيه وبالتحديد حركه الجهات
الاسلامي وضعت شروط من اجل ان يكون هناك
تهدئه اول هذه الشروط وقت سياسه الاغتيال
وتسليم جثمان الاسير المتوفي داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه خضر عدنان وهو يتبع لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي في الاسابيع الماضيه
وايضا وقف مسيره الاعلام التي من المقرر
ان تكون في الثامن عشر من الشهر الجاري
وان يكون وقت اطلاق النار شامل وكامل
اسرائيل رفضت بند وقف السياسات سياسه
الاغتيال وايضا رفضت بند وقف مسيره
الاعلام المقرر في الثامن عشر من الشهر
الجاري فبالتالي نحن امام
معضلات وايضا كان اصطدمت هذه المفاوضات
اغتيال
النائب اللي هو نائب وحده الوحده
الصاروخيه في قطاع غزه احمد ابو دقه قبل
ساعات وايضا مساء كان هناك اغتيال لمسؤول
الوحده الصاروخيه علي غالي المفاوضات
اصطدمت بهذه الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه
لعناصر الجهاد الاسلامي وتعثرت جهود
الوسيط المصري والامم على الارض فبالتالي
هذه
المعوقات والتحديات واجهت يعني مفاوضات
ومسارات التهديه الا يوجد ضمانات حقيقه
زميلتي فيما يتعلق بالتهدئه على الارض في
القطاع هناك خروقات اسرائيليه دائما لاي
اتفاق يمكن ان يكون على الارض ومع الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه فبالتالي
الوسيط المصري يلعب دور كبير وهو يتعرض
لضغوط من قبل الطرفين انفصال الفلسطينيه
وايضا الجانب الاسرائيلي الذي يعني يرفض
العديد من بنود وشروط حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي ومعها الفصائل الفلسطينيه سيد
احمد اود ان اعرف اكثر عن الاوضاع
الانسانيه الان بقطاع غزه وايضا الطبيه
والان هيئه البث الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن
وابل كثيف من الصواريخ يسقط على مستوطنات
غلاف غزه خاصه بما انه المعابر جميعها
مغلقه المعابر معابر الافراد وحتى معبر او
منفذ كرم ابو سالم اللي هو مخصص لادخال
المعدات الطبيه وايضا المنفذ التجاري
الوحيد وبالتالي ذلك يزيد من الخناق على
قطاع غزه
نعم لليوم الثالث اغلاق المعابر معبر ايرز
الشماليه القطاع ومعبر كارما ابو سالم
المعبر الوحيد التجاري مع قطاع غزه الذي
يدخل منه السولار المخصص لمحطه التوليد
الكهرباء يعني انت تعرفي ان الكهرباء في
قطاع غزه هي ثمان ساعات وصل وثمان ساعات
قطع فبالتالي السولار الذي يمد ويزود محطه
الكهرباء
لتوليد الكهرباء يتوقف لثلاثه ايام هناك
كميه محدده لايام ولكن اذا استمر اغلاق
المعابر سوف نواجه ازمه كهرباء حاده
وقاسيه خاصه وان المستشفيات تعتمد على
الكهرباء وان المستشفيات لا تعمل دون
كهرباء ونحن نتحدث عن تصعيد نتحدث عن
اصابات تتوالى الى المستشفيات وهناك
عمليات جراحيه وغيرها من المواد
الاستهلاكيه الطبيه فبالتالي اغلاق
المعابر يعمق الازمه الانسانيه في القطاع
والازمه الاقتصاديه هذا التصعيد يترافق
اصلا ازمات متعدده وسلسله من الازمات التي
يتعرض لها القطاع خاصه مع استمرار الحصاره
الاسرائيلي منذ 16 عاما
فبالتالي الازمه مستمره وسوف تستمر اكثر
وتتعمق اكثر مع استمرار التصعيد
الاسرائيلي والعمليه العسكريه على قطاع
غزه هذا فيما يتعلق بمعبر كرم ابو سالم
معبر ايرز هو ايضا لحركه الافراد والمرضى
من والى القطاع هناك اكثر من 142
مريض ومرافقيهم حرموا لمده ثلاثه ايام من
التوجه الى مستشفيات الضفه والقدس لتلقي
العلاج هناك خمس حالات خطيره في مستشفيات
القطاع كما اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
ان خمس حالات خطيره من بين الذين ينتظرون
من اجل فتح معبر ايرز والتوجه لتلقي
العلاج والجرعات
الكيماوي لمرضى السرطان في مستشفيات الضفه
الغربيه والقدس وبالتالي الازمه الانسانيه
في القطاع تتعمق قبل قليل كانت هناك
تصريحات لوكاله الاونروا وتقول بان
استمرار التصعيد الاسرائيلي سوف يزيد من
حده الازمه الاقتصاديه والانسانيه على
اثنين مليون لاجئ فلسطيني في في قطاع غزه
وهي تطالب الطرفين بوقف التصعيد من اجل ان
يتسنى لها بالعمل على توفير وتلبيه
الاحتياجات الانسانيه
للاجئين الذي تقدم لهم الخدمات والمساعدات
النقديه والتموينيه من اجل يعني ان
يستمروا في العيش بحياه كريمه فبالتالي
نحن امام مشهد انساني صعب وقاسي في قطاع
غزه في حال استمر هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي
والعمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه على قطع
غزه شكرا جزيلا لك احمد حرب من غزه
اظهرت مشاهد جديده اطلاق الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه لرشقات من
الصواريخ باتجاه العمق الاسرائيلي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا من حدود قطاع غزه زياده حلبي
مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين اهلا بك زياد
اذا نتنياهو يبدا اجتماعا لتقييم الوضع
الامني في مقر وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
ضعنا باخر التحديثات الميدانيه والسياسيه
قبل تقريبا عشر دقائق كانت الرشقات
الصاروخيه الاخيره التي اطلقت من قطاع غزه
اتجاه مستوطنات غلاف غزه تجاه سديروت
وتجاه مدينه عسقلان عمليا هذه جاءت
امتدادا لثلاث ساعات يعني اكاد اقول انها
اطلاق رشقات الصاروخيه لم يتوقف تقريبا
فيها عشرات الصواريخ نتحدث عن اكثر من 600
صاروخ عدد الصواريخ التي اطلقت من قطاع
غزه اتجاه اسرائيل اليوم ايضا كان لافتا
وكما كان متوقعا استهداف وسط اسرائيل اكثر
من مره اعتراض صواريخ في سماء ريشونلدسيون
وسط اسرائيل
واصابه مباشره في حوفوت مقتل مستوطن
واصابه ثلاثه عشر اخرين بالاضافه الى
منطقه باتيام ايضا مدينه باتيام وسط
اسرائيل اصابه مجمع تجاري وحاله هلع كبيره
في تلك المنطقه اصابه خمسه منازل في
مستوطنه التي تبعد عنها نح يعني كيلو
مترين وهناك ايضا كان تطور كذا ليكون
دراماتيكيا اصابه سياره وزيره الاستيطان
اريد ستروك عمليا
وشهدت وهي تتفقد اثار الشظايا على السياره
بعد سقوط صاروخ بالقرب من سياراتها في
ايضا الان نتنياهو يجري تقريبا امنيا وهو
ليس فقط تقييم لان هذا الجسم الذي يجتمع
الان الذي اسميناه المطبخ الامني المصغر
مع وزير الدفاع ومستشار الامن القومي
رؤساء الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه هو من يتخذ
القرارات العملانيه حول الاستمرار المتوقع
مزيد ربما من محاولات اغتيال كوادر
وقيادات في الجهاد الاسلامي هذه الليله
عمليا بعد الحديث عن ان هناك تعثرا في
التوصل الى وقف لاطلاق النار وان كان هذا
الحديث قد يكون مؤقتا جدا
زياد هل هنالك من اتهامات او انتقادات
توجه من المعارضه الاسرائيليه او من
مسؤولين امنيين للحكومه ولينا نتنياهو
للتوقف عن الاستمرار في هذه
العمليه لانه عاده لا يحصل هكذا دمار لا
تصل الصواريخ الفلسطينيه الى هذا العمق
الاسرائيلي وحتى هنالك الان خسائر بشريه
هل من ضغوطات داخليه على نتنياهو
هناك جدل داخل يعني المشاورات الامنيه ليس
فقط في هذه النقطه ما يقلق اسرائيل ولكن
هناك خوف من ان نقطه تكتيكيه قد تصبح ورطه
استراتيجيه بمعنى اسرائيل في اسرائيل
يدركون بانه تم تجاوز نقطه ما كان بالامس
الحديث بان الطرفين يلامسان وقفا لاطلاق
النار اليوم نتحدث ان ذلك لم يعد وكانه
على طاوله البحث هذه النقطه التي فيها
اسرائيل بانها اذا لم توقف هذه الحمله على
قطاع غزه في وقت قريب جدا قد تلفي نفسها
في حرب شامله قد تدخل حماس بكامل قوتها في
هذه الحرب عندها الاعتبارات ستصبح اخرى
حرب من اسابيع تدميريه عمليا وشل اسرائيل
بالكامل لفتره طويله هذا ما لا تريده
اسرائيل في هذه اللحظه ولهذا هذه المعضله
الحقيقيه التي يدرس الان امنيا في
الكواليس كيف التصرف هل
ربما يعني يغري اسرائيل المزيد من
الاغتيالات في صفوف كوادر الجهاد بثمن انت
يكون هناك حرب شامله ان تتوقف هذه العمليه
عمليا وكما قلت دائما في الخواتيم في
النهايات تكون ضربات تصعيديه من الجانبين
محاوله لرسم مشهد ختامي فيه بين مزدوجين
مشهد انتصار بالنسبه لاسرائيل حديث متواتر
عن الاغتيالات
المتعاقبه لقيادات الجهاد بالنسبه للجهاد
الاسلامي استهداف تل ابيب مرات عده مقتل
مستوطن وشل اسرائيل على بعد على عمق 80
كيلومترا وبالتالي حتى في ظل الحديث عن
تعثر المفاوضات حول وقف اطلاق النار قد
يكون هذا الامر باعتقادي مؤقتا جدا شكرا
جزيلا لك زياد حلبي من حدود قطاع غزه مدير
مكتب العربيه في فلسطين
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم من جديد في تطورات الحرب
باوكرانيا قلقائد قوات فاغنار ان القوات
الاوكرانيه بدات بالفعل الهجوم المضاده
بعد تلقي التدريب والمعدات العسكريه
اللازمه
بالنسبه للهجوم المضاد
الهجوم المضاد يمضي بسرعه وعلى قدم وساق
تهاجم وحدات من الجيش الاوكراني محور
باخموت وللاسف هم ينجحون بذلك كما ذكرت
مرات عده فان خطه القوات الاوكرانيه
تتمحور في خنقنا نحن نحاول خنقهم وهم
يحاولون كذلك هم يحتاجون اولا الى التخلص
من عناصر فاجنر في محور باخموت ثم التوجه
بكامل الامكانيات الى زباروجيا وبريانس
ولذلك فان الهجوم الاوكرانيه بدا لقد
حصلوا بالفعل على المعدات العسكريه
اللازمه وعلى التدريب اللازم عناصر فاجنر
تواصل مهامها القتاليه رغم عدم وجود
الذخائر والدعم الذي وعدت به وزاره الدفاع
باسعار روسيه الكرام لان خطط بريطانيا
لتزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيده المدى وقال
المتحدث باسم الكريم ان هذه الخطوه التي
وصفها بالسلبيه ستتطلب ردا مناسبا من
الجيش الروسي
واعلنت اوكرانيا عن تسجيل
2194 هجوما وحديثا الكترونيا منذ يناير من
العام الماضي ضد شبكات النقل او الاتصالات
او الطاقه او التمويل وقال رئيس جهاز
الاتصالات وحمايه المعلومات الاوكرانيه
الجنرال اوليكساندر بوتشي ان شده الهجمات
الالكترونيه الروسيه تتقلب بين ارتفاع
وانخفاض الا ان
85% منها يستهدف القطاعات المدنيه
الاوكرانيه
نسمع عن الهجمات السيبرانيه او حتى
الالكترونيه لكن لنتعرف مشاهدينا اكثر على
هذه
المصطلحات او هذا المصطلح تحديدا هذا
الهجوم محاوله متعمده من جانب فرد او
مؤسسه او دوله ما لاختراق نظام المعلومات
لدى جهه اخرى وهي بدورها قد تكون فردا او
شركه او حتى دوله هناك عدد من الانواع
الشائعه من الهجمات السيبرانيه منها
البرامج الضاره او الخبيثه بما في ذلك
برامج التجسس وبرامج الفديه الهجمات
السيبرانيه ومنذ وقت ليس بالقليل اصبحت
جزءا من الحرب الالكترونيه التي تقوم بها
الدول ضد خصومها من هنا يصبح الهجوم
السيبراني سلاحا بمقدوره احداث اضرار
جسيمه وطويله الامد مثل الاطاحه بنظام حكم
او التمهيد لحرب او تخريب قطاعات تؤثر على
حياه السكان ومع ازدياد حده المواجهه
السيبرانيه بين الاول وفي حالتي السلمي او
الحرب تتنافس الدول على تعزيز مكانتها
وتوفير قدرات تؤهلها لشن هجمات سيبرانيه
مدمره وفي ذات الوقت تضع حكومات الدول
المختلفه الامن السيبراني في قلب
استراتيجيات الامن القومي الذي بات جزءا
مهما من حمايه الدول نشير اخيرا الى ان
الخسائر الماليه جراء الهجمات الالكترونيه
خلال العام الماضي تجاوزت عشره مليارات
دولار تخيلوا هذا الرقم بحسب تقرير لمكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي الامريكي ومن باريس
ينضم الينا امين حاسبيني الباحث والخبير
التقني في امن المعلومات اهلا بك سيد امين
يعني ارقام وخسائر كبيره بالمليارات 10
مليارات هي خسائر الدول نتيجه الهجمات
السيبرانيه
بما يخص الحروب بما يخص واذا اخذنا الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
كمثال الى اي مدى الثارات الهجمات
السيبرانيه على نتائج الحرب وعلى الخسائر
بين الطرفين
جميل مساء الخير طبعا لما نتحدث نحن عن
الهجمات يعني وخاصه في الحالات اللي هي
الاستثنائيه مثل حالات الحروب يعني مثل
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه نتحدث عن انتشار
لعده انواع من المهاجمين هنالك المهاجم
الاجرامي ونحن نتابع من بدايه السنه
الماضيه عدد كبير من الفرق الاجراميه يلي
هي حول العالم وحتى العربيه منها خاصه في
شمال افريقيا
كان لديهم اصطفاف مع الجهات المتواجده في
الحرب يعني كان لديهم اصطفاف ومحاولات
هجوم واستباق للاحداث في في مناطق النزاع
ان كان هجمات على الافراد المؤسسات او
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه نتحدث عن الطاقه
المياه او او غيره
فهذا من ناحيه
الفرق الاجراميه لكن هناك طبعا الفرق
المتقدمه التي هي لديها امكانيات شبه غير
مح وتستخدم تقنيات احدث ويعني بامكانها
القيام باضرار اكبر وهي ايضا تتواجه يعني
الهجمات هي من جميع الاطراف يعني ان كان
المتحاربه او الغير متحاربه تخيلي حتى في
في فرق اللي هي تعتبر نيوترول او غير
متحيزه هي ليست غير متحيزه بالمعنى انه هي
تتفرج لا هي غير متحيزه بمعنى انه هي
تهاجم الاثنين او الجهات المتصارعه بنفس
الوقت فبالتالي بامكانها عندما تهاجم من
طرف الاول الاختباء كانها الطرف الثاني او
عندما تهاجم الطرف الثاني هي تختبئ كطرف
الاول سيد امين لماذا عاده لا نعلم او لا
يعلم من استهدف الدوله لدوله اخرى او يعني
كان وراء الهجوم
السيبراني يعني وحتى انه الهجمات
السيبرانيه اصبحت اداه سياسيه عندما تريد
دوله القيام بخطوه محاسبه او عقوبه او
اتهام لدوله اخرى
سؤال سؤال ممتاز لما نتحدث عن العمل
الجنائي في امن المعلومات اولا نتحدث عن
يعني خصوصا في موضوع الهجمات الهجمات
الامن السيبراني او التقنيات التي تستخدم
التقنيات بامكان بالامكان نسخها مثل ما هي
يعني انا وصل وصل مثلا او فيروس مثلا يؤثر
على شبكات المياه مثلا في دوله معينه تم
اكتشافه هيدا نفسه
لاخذ الملف نفسه وضعه فيه مؤسسه في دوله
مختلفه كليا تمام
ويقوم بنفس العمل هذه مشكله التحقيقات
الجنائيه في في امن المعلومات هي انه هويه
الداتا وهويه الهجوم صعب جدا التحقق منها
في نطاق في نطاق
الامن السيبراني هون يدخل طبعا الحاجه او
ما تستخدمه الدول اللي هي الامكانيات
الغير سيبرانيه في الوصول يعني عسكريه
للوصول الى الى يعني هويه افضل باختصار لو
سمحت الهجمات السيبرانيه مرتبطه دائما
بذهننا وبما يتداول به الامن القومي تحدث
بين دوله واخرى على مستوى الافراد كيف
نتاثر نحن
التاثير التاثير ياتي على عده مراحل طبعا
هون هون ينعكس ايضا على على المسؤوليات
اللي هي على عده على عده مستويات التاثير
ياتي طبعا على الافراد اللي هي قد تتاثر
حياتهم الماليه او الماديه او حتى لما
نتحدث عن هجمات على البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه قد يكون تاثير حيوي ايضا على
الحياه نفسها ان كان مثلا صار في احداث
مثلا انقطاع الكهرباء في اماكن معينه او
تخلي حدا مثلا يتحكم بالسيارات الذكيه او
بالمواصلات او او مثلا الهجمات على
المفاعلات النوويه او غيره فطبعا الاضرار
قد تكون مدمره طبعا على امل ان لا نصل الى
هذا الحد المسؤوليات بالمقابل هي ايضا على
مستويات ومراحل من الفرد داخل منزله الى
الى المؤسسات الى الى الحكومات طبعا لكل
لكل فرد ولكل مؤسسه لاجراءات حسب حسب
تخصصها
شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس امين حاسبيني
الباحث والخبير التقني في امن المعلومات
[موسيقى]
نبره حاده اتجاه دول العالم غير الاوروبيه
تقابلها لغه ناعمه تجاع الصين في ملف
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تجلت في
تصريحات المسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
دبلوماسيه متقلبه ولهجه اوروبيه متغيره
بتغير الظروف هذا ما بدت عليه تصريحات
جوزيف بوريل بين اليوم وامس لغه غير
الدبلوماسيه خطب بها بوريل كل الدول غير
الاوروبيه في اطار ملف الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا خاصه دول جنوب الكره الارضيه
ماذا يعني ولكن نعم ولكن لا نقبل نعم ولكن
هناك غزو
تصريحات غير مفاجئه فقد سبقها تشبيه اثار
غضب العالم فاوروبا حديقه مقارنه ببقيه
دول العالم التي وصفها بالادغال
[موسيقى]
العالم ليس حديقه بل معظمه ادغال ويمكن
للادغال ان تغزو الحديقه
يجب على اوروبا ان تتخلى عن عقليه ان
مشاكلها هي مشاكل العالم اما مشاكل العالم
ليست مشاكل اوروبا
اما باتجاه الشرق فقد خفت حده النبره ليصف
بوريد الصين التي لا تختلف مواقفها كثيرا
عن دول الجنوب يصفها بالقوه العظمى
والسؤال المطروح هو كيف ستستخدم قوتها في
حرب روسيا واوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
والعديد من قاده اوروبا وصف الصين كاكثر
شريك تجاريا في عده محافل فالشراكه
الصينيه الاوروبيه باتت اليوم تنمو بشكل
اكبر من ذي قبل بل وحتى على حساب الشراكه
الاوروبيه الامريكيه
اذا عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
فيما يتواصل الاقتتال في السودان تستمر
المحادثات بين وفدي الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في جذابه بواسطه سعوديه وامريكيه
الناطق باسم العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر
يوسف اكد ان تفاؤلا حذرا بات يلوح في
الافق على الرغم من الاشتباكات المستمره
في العاصمه الخرطومه وان المباحثات في جده
باتت تقترب من التوصل الى اتفاق وقف اطلاق
نار في اي لحظه كما اشار الى احتمال اتفاق
الجيش ودعم السريع على انهاء الازمه
والاقتتال الزائر في السودان وشدد الناطق
باسم العمليه السياسيه على ان حل الازمه
التي تعيشها البلاد هو الخيار السني
وفق مبادره سودانيه بعنوان مفقود اختفاء
اكثر من 190 مدنيا منذ بدء المعارك بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع نتابع
اثر بعد عين لم يتبقى منهم الا صور
مفقود الحرب كارثه السودان الجديده
اكثر من 190 مفقودا حتى الان 54 مفقوده
خلال اسبوع واحد
اغلبهم مدنيون من الخرطوم وام درمان متوسط
اعمار معظمهم ما بين 20 و 35 عاما
اثنى عشر بالمئه منهم من كبار السن
عده بلاغات تتلقاها مبادره بعنوان مفقود
تسعى الى حصر اعدادهم يوميا وظروف
اختفائهم
[موسيقى]
مناشدات للبحث عنهم ميدانيا وبين جثث
مجهوله
اعداد المفقودين مرشحه للازدياد مع
استمرار المعارك
[موسيقى]
المحكمه العليا الباكستانيه باطلاق سراح
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران وقالت المحكمه
العليا ان اعتقال عمران خان لم يكن
قانونيا وان عليه المثول مره اخرى امام
محكمه اسلام اباد العليا من جهته قال رئيس
الوزراء السابق انه تم اختطافه من محكمه
اسلام اباد العليا وتعرض للضرب على يد
قوات الامن واضاف عمران خان انه لم يكن
على علم بالاضطرابات التي حدثت في البلاد
عقب اعتقاله في حين طلبت السلطات
الباكستانيه المحكمه وعمرا خان بمطالبه
انصاره بالبقاء سلميين والتنديد باعمال
الشغب فيما تواجه البلاد اضطرابات في
الشوارع
[موسيقى]
في لقاء مثير للجدل على سي ان ان يهاجم
على كل الجبهات تابعونا بعد الف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا المرشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه محرم انجي انسحابهم من
السباق الانتخابيه فيما يواصل بقيه
الناخبين معركتهم او المقدمين عليه يعني
المتنافسين معركتهم الانتخابيه يوم الاحد
المقبل
تتقلص خيارات الناخب التركي ويحتدم السباق
في معركه انتخابيه ربما تكون هي الاصعب في
تاريخ الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
فهذا محرم ان جاء زعيم حزب البلد يرفع
الرايه البيضاء وينسحب من السباق
الانتخابي قبيل ايام من الاقتراع
اسحب اسمي من الترشح للرئاسه وانسحبوا من
السباق انا افعل ذلك من اجل بلدي حاولت
توفير قناه جديده للناخبين لكنني فشلت
عندما تخسر المعارضه في الانتخابات
سيلوموننا فلن نعطيهم اي اعذار اريد
تصويتا من كل بيت لحزب الوطن ولكنني انسحب
من الترشح للرئاسه
[تصفيق]
اما المرشح عن تحالف الاجداد سنانوجان فما
زال يواصل نضاله حتى النهايه ونفى
الشائعات عن تمهيده للانسحاب
فيما يواصل زعيم حزب الشعب كمال كليتش دار
اوغلو المنافس الابرز لرجب طيب اردوغان
برنامجه الانتخابي الذي عرف ببساطه واتخذ
من تحصين الواقع المعيشي نقطه بدايه
وارتكاز لسياسته
اما اردوغان المحارب للفوز بعقد ثالث لحكم
البلاد فوعد بجمهوريه منفتحه على العالم
اجمع
وبين من يعد بجعل تركيا قويه منفتحه وبين
من يدعو لجعلها ديموقراطيه يبقى الفصل بيد
الناخبين الذين ستحدد اوراق اقتراعهم اسم
الرئيس المقبل لتركيا سلام المحاميد
العربيه
[موسيقى]
ايام قلائل تفصلنا عن الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه ومعرفه ما ان كانت البلاد الوجهه
التي ستسلكها خلال الاعوام المقبله سنركز
في هذا العرض على الجوانب الاقتصاديه
والديموغرافيه وارقام لها دلالات في هذه
الانتخابات التركيه نبدا من الليره
التركيه فخلال الولايه الحاليه للرئيس
التركي فقدت اكثر من سبعه وسبعين في المئه
من قيمتها وحسب احصاءات ابريل الماضي
ارتفعت اسعار المواد الغذائيه بنسبه 45%
ايضا نسبه التضخم تجاوزت 43 في المئه كما
ان معدل البطاله في تركيا بقي دون تغيير
عند 10% الزلزال طبعا الذي وقع في فبراير
الماضي زاد من الاعباء على شاغر القصر
الرئاسي اردوغان فوفقا لي تقديرات الامم
المتحده اضرار الناجمه عن هذا الزلزال
ستتجاوز المئه مليار دولار من الجانب
الاقتصادي ننتقل للناخبين الذين سيكون
ثمانيه في المئه منهم هم من الناخبين
الذين سيصوتون لاول مره ويرى الكثيرون
انهم في اكبر مجموعه من الناخبين
المتارجحين نختم مع الفئه الاخرى السوريون
الحاصلون على الجنسيه التركيه الذين يحق
لهم التصويت في هذه الانتخابات نذكر هنا
انه في يوليو من عام 2016 طلب الرئيس
التركي منح جزء من اللاجئين السوريين خاصه
اصحاب الكفاءات العلميه والمهنيه الجنسيه
التركيه وهو ما اقره البرلمان وخلال
السنوات الماضيه حصل
230 الف سوري على الجنسيه التركيه من
بينهم ما يقارب
130,000ا يحق لهم التصويت في هذه
الانتخابات الحاليه الارقام يعني انا نسبه
السوريين القادرين على التصويت في
الانتخابات المقبله من مجموع اعداد
السوريين في تركيا هي
3.66 بالمئه حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
ضيفنا من اسطنبول
زاهد جول رئيس تحرير اندبندنت تركيا اهلا
بك سيد زاهد يعني حسب هذا العرض وهذه
الارقام
نبدا من موضوع التضخم من موضوع
يعني البطاله ارتفعت الاسعار اسعار المواد
الغذائيه
الكثير من الاعباء الاقتصاديه على كاهل
المواطن التركي الى اي مدى
المال الليره التركيه التضخم
يؤثرون على مزاج الناخب التركي
ولمن يعني الدفه هنا تميل
بدايه التحيه الطيبه لك ولجميع المشاهدين
قناتكم اعتقد ان العامل الاقتصادي كما
تفضلت هو اهم العوامل الرئيسيه التي تغير
المزاج العام لدى الشارع التركي الذي هو
غير مصنف ابتداء وانتهاء بمعنى انه غير
مؤدلج وغير منتسب حزبيا بمعنى انه لديه
القابليه لتغيير صوته السياسي ابتداء
هذه النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه وهي اهم
في رايي الشخصي ما تفضلت به من ارقام هي
ارقام رسميه لكن واقع الحال في تركيا
والكثير من الجهات المستقله التي تقيم
الواقع الاقتصادي التركي تتحدث عن خسائر
وارقام تضخم اكثر من ذلك بكثير انتم قلتم
مثلا على سبيل المثال ان ارقام التضخم
اربعين بالمئه بينما الواقع الفعلي الذي
يعيشه المواطن التركي وحال اي انسان تركي
يقول ان التضخم تجاوز المئه بالمئه فعليا
خلال الماضيه حتى الرواتب ننظر مثلا الى
زياده الرواتب الرسميه سواء ادنى الاجور
وغيرها من الرواتب فهي تجاوزت الضعف اكثر
من مئه بالمئه مما يؤكد ان ارقام التضخم
ايضا تجاوزت هذا العدد ايضا بالنسبه
لارقام البطاله قلتم ارقام رسميه وهذه
ارقام غير واقعيه حسب المعارضه وحسب
الكثير من الجهات المستقله ايضا وبالتالي
من المؤكد ان هناك واقع اقتصاديا مريرا
يعيشه الواقع التركي خاصه اننا نتحدث ان
الاتراك غالبيتهم العظمى من الطبقه
المتوسطه وهذه الطبقه المتوسطه انعدمت
حقيقه خلال السنوات الثلاث الماضيه يعني
الاستاذ الجامعي على سبيل المثال الذي كان
يتقاضى قرابه 2500 دولار تقريبا او ما
يعادل هذا الرقم خلال الاعوام الماضيه
وكان لديه قدره شرائيه جيده الى حد كبير
الان يتقاضى فعليا قراب 800 دولار
ولا اتحدث بطبيعه الحال عن ادنى الاجور
وبالتالي على ماذا هناك تعول المعارضه
التركيه نتحدث عن ما هي نقاط الضعف
يعني حكومه اردوغان التي يعني تسوق لها
تلقي الضوء عليها
واستجابه الشارع لخطاب المعارضه اعتقد
بالنسبه
بالنسبه للوعود الاقتصاديه والنظره
الاقتصاديه اعتقد ان السيد اردوغان لم
يستطع حقيقه ان يقدم للجمهور التركي
ابتداء وانتهاء ما يشفي غليله او ما
يطمئنه لمستقبله يعني كان هناك قبل ايام
او قبل نحو شهر تقريبا من الان عوده عن
عوده لوزير الماليه الاسبق محمد شمشك من
للعمل في
مع اردوغان في احدى الوزارات وخاصه وزاره
الاقتصاد او وزاره الماليه مثل هذا مثل
هذه الاخبار التي بست عبر رويترز بشكل عام
اعطت املا بان يكون هناك تغيير في المشهد
الاقتصادي وفي نظريات اردوغان الاقتصاديه
وفي الصيغه التي يدير فيها الاقتصاد ان ان
ممكن ان هناك احتماليه التغيير بعد
الانتخابات لكن عدم عوده هذا الشخص عوده
عوده الوزير الاسبق الى راس الى راس عمله
او قبوله لدعوه اردوغان وعدم وبالعكس
تصريحاته انه لن يعمل مع في هذه الفتره مع
اردوغان لاسباب صحيه او التزاماته باعمال
اخرى مع في لندن وغيرها مثل هذه الاخبار
حقيقه جعلت الامال شبه مفقوده في اداره
اردوغان
العديد نعم نعم ولكن يعني هنا انت تتحدث
وكانه اردوغان لا يمتلك نقاط قوه هو لديه
نقاط قوه اولا يعني كما تحدثنا بالارقام
اعداد السوريين الذين منحهم الجنسيه لابد
انهم سيصوتون له ايضا كان بالبدايه ببدايه
الزلزال كان هناك انتقادات لتعامل الحكومه
والادارات الرسميه مع الزلزال لاحقا كان
هناك رضا ايضا
تركيا تحولت في عهد اردوغان الى دوله
مصنعه للصناعات ثقيله يعني هناك محاولات
كبرى لانضمامها للاتحاد
الاوروبي ايضا هناك نقاط قوه يمتلك الرجل
يعني لا شك نحن لا نتحدث عن نقاط القوه
والضعف كنا نتحدث فقط في الجانب الاقتصادي
ابتداء وانتهاء وبالنسبه
لاردوغان عموما لا شك انه يمتلك الكثير من
نقاط القوه ويمتلك كل ادوات الدوله ابتداء
وانتهاء في حملته الانتخابيه وفي خطابه
السياسي الى استدخال كل ما تقوم به وزاره
الدفاع والجيش التركي من صناعاته وغيرها
في ضمن حملته الانتخابيه مما يعني يستنكره
الاخرون حقيقه لان هذه الصناعات وطنيه قبل
كل شيء ولا تخص حزبا سياسيا معينا
وبالتالي لا شك ان اردوغان يمتلك القوه في
هذا السياق اكثر من غيره من الاطراف
الاخرى بما فيها قوه الاعلام وقوه التاثير
وادوات الدوله بجميعها كلها مفروشه امامه
ليستخدمها في حملته الانتخابيه بينما
المعارضه محرومه من ذلك بطبيعه الحال لكن
بالنسبه للجانب الاقتصادي اعتقد ان
المعارضه استطاعت في رايي الشخص تقديم
اوراق اعتمادي هذه نقطه اساسيه النقطه
الثانيه بالنسبه لاصوات السوريين وغيرهم
انا لا اعتقد انها ليست بذاك الكم الذي
تستطيع تغيير النتيجه بمعنى نحن نتحدث عن
64 مليون ناخب تركي يحق لهم التصويت واذا
ما اخذنا ان نسبه التصويت لن تقل عن قرابه
التسعين بالمئه تقريبا من الشعب التركي
مما يحق لهم التصويت نحن نتحدث عن قرابه
60 مليون ناقد تقريبا سيتوجه فعليا الى
صندوق الاقتراع او 58 او 58 مليون تقريبا
وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن 200,000 او 300
الف او حتى نصف مليون شخص انا اعتقد انهم
لن يغيروا في المعادله الانتخابيه الشيء
الكثير اذا ما استطاعت المعارضه فعليا
تقديم اوراق اعتمادها ليس فقط في الجانب
الاقتصادي فحسب بل في جوانب اخرى يعني
الوعود التي اطلقتها المعارضه وهذا الامر
تحديدا اليوم حقيقه اواخر استطلاعات الراي
التي نشرت فقط والتي اشارت الى تقدم نسبي
واضح
المعارضه مع انسحاب ايضا محرم انجا
البورصه التركيه
يعني اخذت نقاط ايجابيه بنقطه بعشر نقاط
تقريبا
والسندات التركيه تجاوزت ارباحها اكثر من
20% مجرد
الشعور بفوز المعارضه او اقتراب من فوز
المعارضه بمعنى ان الجانب الاقتصادي
تحديدا لا شك انه هو اقرب للدعم المعارضه
او الشارع ايضا يرى ذلك اكثر من جهه
اردوغان بشكل واضح وصريح شكرا جزيلا لك من
اسطنبول زاهد جول رئيس تحرير اند باندا
تركيا
مرشح الرئاسه التركيه المعارض كمال كليتش
دار اوغلو اسم اتفقت عليه احزاب عده ليس
ثقه به فقط ربما بل رغبه بازاحه اردوغان
عن كرسي السلطه نتعرف على هذه الاحزاب
واهميتها مع الزميله روان حمزه
في السباق الرئاسي التركي اقتصر المشهد
على متنافسين رئيسيين هما الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان والمعارض كمال كالجدار
اوغلو لم يسبق ان اعتبر كلش دار اوغلو
محطه امال المعارضه لكنه استطاع في
النهايه الانتصار بالقبول به كمرشح مشترك
التفاف لم يكن برضى الاغلبيه لكنه تم رغبه
من احزاب المعارضه بمواجهه اردوغان فاضطرت
لتوحيد صفوفها بتجمع سته احزاب تحت ما سمي
الطاوله السداسيه قبل ان تعيد تسميه
التحالفها تحالف الامه بقياده كالجدار
اوغلو صاحب الكتله الاكبر في البرلمان
وزعيم اكبر تحالف معارض كل جدار اوغلو لم
يفوز باي انتخابات ضد اردوغان منذ تولي
الاخير السلطه عام 2002 وواجه ضغوطا لثنيه
عن الترشح للرئاسه رغم ذلك وجدت المعارضه
نفسها مضطره للقبول بالامر الواقع لهدف
واحد الاطاحه بارتوجان تغيير النظام
السياسي
اقتصاديه مختلفه جذريا والاهم تبني نهج
مختلف كليا عنه في السياسه الخارجيه
اختياره كل جدار اوغلو مرشحا مشتركا بعد
خلافات عميقه قد يهدد بتفجير ازمات في اي
لحظه لذا سيجد كلجدار اوغلو نفسه امام
صراع قديم جديد فحلفاء اليوم هم اعداء
الامس القواعد الحزبيه المحافظه الداعمه
له السعاده الديمقراطيه والتقدم المستقبل
لديها عداء تاريخي ما احزاب اليسار ممثله
بحزب الشعب الجمهوري ورئيسه
اعدائه كالجدار اوغلو ليسوا فقط من احزاب
المعارضه لكنهم داخل حزبه خسارته
الانتخابات الرئاسيه قد تفجر غضبا عارما
وتتسبب بتفتت اصوات المعارضه خاصه وان
كلجدار اوغلو حاول ان يتقرب من المحافظين
رغم ايدولوجيا الحزب العلمانيه وضم
بقوائمه حلفاء السابق لاردوغان امر اثار
حفيظه قواعد حزبيه معار ضه واثار مخاوفه
من تاثير سلبي على المعدل التصويطي للحزب
وحظوظ الطاوله السداسيه
[موسيقى]
في اول ظهور له منذ العام 2016
ظهر الرئيس الامريكي السابق دون الترامب
على شبكه سي ان ان بعد سنوات من التوتر
والقطعه مع الشبكه لم يوفر تلك المساحه
واستثمرها جيدا كعادته فانتقد وهاجم على
كل الجهات
لا يختلفوا دونالد ترامب فهو المعتد
المتحدي والمنت
قد تختلف اطلالته هذه المره فيطل عبر شبكه
سي ان ان في اول ظهور لهم منذ العام 2016
على الشبكه اطلاله يقول خبراء انها محسوبه
جيدا في توقيتها ومكانها استثمرها ترامب
انتخابيا واطلق سهامه في كل الاتجاهات
رئيس السابق جدد رفضه الاعتراف بخساره
الانتخابات الرئاسيه امام الجو بايدن
واصل انتقادته لاداره بايدن ازمه سقف
الدين العام كانت حاضره ما نفعله الان
اننا ننفق المال مثل البحاره المخمورين
خارجيا والى الحرب في اوكرانيا يثق الرئيس
السابق بقدرته على وقف الحرب وبسرعه سافعل
ذلك في غضون 24 ساعه انت بحاجه الى قوه
الرئاسه للقيام بذلك لكن ماذا عن موقفه ان
كان يريد لاوكرانيا الانتصار ام لا لا
افكر فيما يتعلق بالفوز والخساره اعتقد من
ناحيه يجب تسويه الامر حتى نتوقف عن قتل
كل هؤلاء الاشخاص لقاء جدد فيه ترامب
مواقفه وعادته في مهاجمه الجميع حتى
المذيعه طالها من الانتقادات نصيب لست
شخصا جيدا لا تعلمين عما تتحدثين ينتهي
اللقاء فيسارع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الى التعليق قائلا هل تريدون فعلا اربع
سنوات اخرى من هذا اذا كنتم لا تريدون ذلك
فساهموا في حملتنا
تصريح اليوم عن العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
باوكرانيا وانها مستمره ولكنها صعبه جدا
تلك كلمات المتحدث باسم رئاسه الروسيه
في اشاره الى الهجوم الذي تفشونه ركوات
روسيا في اوكرانيا لفت ايضا في مقابله
تلفزيونيه الى تحقق بعض اهداف هذه العمليه
قذيفه سقطت على بعد 500 متر كانت قريبه
لكننا نجونا اذا فلنعد للعمل فيجب ان
تستمر الحياه ويجب زرع هذه البذور يقول
احد المزارعين انها مقاطعه ذابوليتجاب
بجنوب اوكرانيا حيث يتربص البؤس
بالمزارعين فمن نجا من الموت واثر البقاء
قرب ارضه عليه ان يكافح ويزرع حتى وان
انخفض سعر محاصيله وارتفعت اسعار الاسمده
عليه العمل انها غريزه الحياه والبقاء وان
سالته عن امنيته يجيب النصر والحصاد الجيد
سوره اليوم من جنوب افريقيا تخيل ان تكون
اخر من يتحدث بلغه اصيله في السابق كنت
تتعرض للاهانه والتنمر اذا تحدثت بها
واليوم تكرم وتمنح دكتوراه فخريه لانك
تجدها لكنك وللاسف لن تجد من تحادثه بها
تلك قصه اوما كاترينا ايسو اخر متحدث
معروف باللغه النوبيه هي جده بالتسعين من
عمرها تحاول جهده تعليمه حفيدتها لغتها
الاصليه عسى ان لا تندثر كغيرها من اللغات
التي انقرضت بفعل الاستعمار
انت هتنشطنا لليله ولكن اخبار الساعه مع
الزميل صهيب شراير تتابع معكم مساء الخير
صهيب ما اهم ملفاتك مساء الخير راويه طبعا
ملفات عديده هي جوله اخباريه سريعه وشامله
لاهم اخبار اليوم في الصداره طبعا يبقى
الوضع الملتهب في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المزيد من الصواريخ تصل الى اسرائيل
وغارات اسرائيليه كذلك مستمره على قطاع
غزه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات